bienvenidos a la presentación de
problemas de aplicación sobre edades
aquí ya tenemos uno en cuatro años al y
tendrá tres veces la edad que tiene
actualmente qué edad tiene al y
actualmente hagamos x x
está muy grande esa equis para lo que
quiero pero bueno no importa sea x
la edad
disculpa mi escritura la edad actual
ideal y así es que esta es la edad real
y el día de hoy y aquí dice en cuatro
años cuál va a ser la edad de alí en
cuatro años pues en cuatro años
tendremos que x más 4 esto va a ser
igual a la edad
la edad de allí
en 4
años que más información nos dan aquí
bueno nos dicen que en cuatro años esto
que tenemos aquí x cuatro en cuatro años
en cuatro años allí tendrá tres veces la
edad que tiene actualmente la edad que
tiene actualmente es x nos dicen que en
cuatro años cuando su edad es x 4 si es
que esto de aquí en cuatro años lo
podemos traducir como x 4 qué pasa esto
va a ser tres veces la edad que tiene
actualmente tres veces la edad que tiene
actualmente
esto es 3x resolvamos esta ecuación
vamos a restar x ambos lados nos queda
2x es igual a 4 de donde x es igual a 2
así es que alí tiene actualmente dos
años de edad podemos checar que esto
cuadra con los datos si actualmente
tiene dos años en cuatro años va a tener
seis años que es tres veces su edad
actual así es que está correcto hagamos
otro problema
bien borremos esto y voy a intentar
teclear el nuevo problema que está
pasando
bien el problema es
micó
es
cuatro años
mayor
ulises
hace dos años
niko
tenía
cinco veces
la edad
de ulises qué edad tiene nico
actualmente este es un problema más
interesante que el anterior y por
supuesto más complicado pero si vamos a
poder resolverlo de nueva cuenta que
queremos encontrar queremos encontrar la
edad de nikko actualmente entonces
hagamos lo siguiente supongamos que aquí
vamos a poner a nico
y aquí abajo vamos a poner
ulises ulises y luego por aquí vamos a
poner
hoy la edad que tienen actualmente y
aquí cuatro años antes no no no es
cuatro años antes es dos años antes me
quedé en el problema anterior la edad
hace dos años
dos años antes muy bien esta tabla va a
ser de gran ayuda para resolver este
problema está un poco chueca mi tabla no
importa nos va a funcionar bastante bien
así que si queremos encontrar cuál es la
edad en icod actualmente vamos a asignar
para la edad de nikko el día de hoy x
nos dicen que nico es cuatro años mayor
que ulises así es que esta información
déjame subrayar la esta información que
nos dan aquí mencionando que niko es
cuatro años mayor que ulises eso nos
permite establecer que si hoy la edad en
icod es x la edad de ulises hoy es x
menos 4 y esto hace sentido pues nos
dicen que niko es cuatro años mayor que
ulises ahora
vayamos al pasado esto esto va a ser así
entonces dos años antes si nico tiene
equis años hoy dos años antes queda
tendría tendría x menos 2 ya ese sentido
supongamos que niko tiene digamos 10
años ahora hace 2 años tendría 10 menos
28 años que pasa con ulises ulises hoy
tiene x menos 4 años
hace 2 años tendría x 4 - 2 y esto es
igual a x menos 6 y hace sentido nota
que aquí también se ve esa diferencia de
cuatro años ahora si te fijas el
problema aún contiene información que no
hemos usado hace dos años
niko
tenía cinco veces la edad de ulises así
es que estamos en este caso aquí estamos
describiendo la situación dos años antes
niko tenía cinco veces la edad y ulises
único cuya edad era x menos 2 tenía
cinco veces la edad de ulises cuya edad
era x 6 escribamos eso matemáticamente
niko hace dos años tenía x menos dos
años en lo que estamos viendo aquí y
esto es igual a cinco veces cinco veces
la edad de ulises que hace dos años era
x menos 6 y ahora simplemente resolvemos
para x tenemos que x 2 es igual a 5 x
menos 30 ahora resto x ambos lados así
que ahora tenemos 4x e intercambiado
lados espero que esto no te confunda -30
esto es igual a menos 2 de donde 4x es
igual a 28 y finalmente x
es igual a 7 hemos resuelto el problema
actualmente nico tiene 7 años de edad
veamos si es esto correcto actualmente
nico tiene 7 años ulises tiene 7 menos 4
que son tres años hay una diferencia en
sus edades de cuatro años
niko hace dos años tenía cinco años y
ulises tenía un año a la sede x igual a
7 obtenemos 7 6 un año así es que está
correcto único es cuatro años mayor que
ulises niko tiene siete años ulises
tiene tres hace dos años nico tenía
cinco veces la edad de ulises hace dos
años nico tenía cinco años y ulises
tenía uno así es que todo funciona
impresionante verdad en fin ya es un par
de problemas relacionados con las edades
voy a hacer más
así es que siempre vas a poder regresar
a este sitio de videos para ver más
vídeos de este tipo y resolver dudas que
te pudieran surgir
espero que la pases muy bien